okay I don't know time for ATM robberies
or the thoughtful notes you leave behind
I have moving day to worry about wait
wait you're moving news movie don't you
watch the news
Tony sold Avengers tower relocating to a
new facility upstate where hopefully the
cell service is much worse what about me
I'll call you back feel free not to the
hell are you guys
[Music]
all the true known is at an end
everybody so I've been getting a lot of
requests for more Marvel x-men crossover
videos in light of infinity war and the
deal going through at Disney even though
it's gonna take about 18 months to make
it through the government because of
antitrust regulation but as you can see
there are some very easy points to slot
in very specific characters also address
Deadpool to because he's a bit of a
different scenario so talking about
Fantastic Four in Deadpool mostly in
this video if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything this Disney Fox deal is
really just the tip of the iceberg even
James Gunn who's doing mostly cosmic
movies in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
they're starting to call that the marble
cosmic universe because of all the new
cosmic based movies that they're gonna
be making the possibilities are endless
now even his brother Sean Gunn was
making jokes now you can use the villain
you really wanted for guardians of the
galaxy 3 in it Sideshow Bob from The
Simpsons because now Disney owns Fox
which owns the Simpsons so the big thing
first
the Baxter building Fantastic Four Tony
sold Avengers Tower we need to be out
it's the easiest thing in the world to
leave that building empty till the end
of Avengers 4 and they want to bring in
the new tenant in some sort of post
credits scene because I think we all
understand that it's a little too soon
to just put all those characters in
there so they'll just make reference to
some things in the x-men Fox universe so
that in three or four years when the
deal goes through or whatever
arrangement they need to make gets made
they can actually use the characters
legit and do whatever they want to with
them Deadpool is kind of an exception to
that but you'll understand why when I
explain but the thing is is that the
Fantastic Four as a group just don't
need to have a ton of their own movies
right away you can use them in Marvel
movies sparingly or just a few
characters like Reed Richards and slot
him into the spider-man homecoming
universe and he just becomes a character
that people talk about then eventually
you can work him in when it makes sense
Sony still has the rights to the
spider-man characters in the film so
they still have to keep their sharing
arrangement to keep him around for
Avengers related stuff but because
Disney bought
phox there's no reason to say why they
can't also reference Fantastic Four
characters during spider-man movies the
deal gets a little bit complicated but
Reed Richards himself is also the key to
the multiverse in addition to Doctor
Strange there's a couple different ways
they can accomplish every single thing
that they want to do and Kevin Feige has
plans depending on what they get the
rights for so he probably had a plan for
x-men characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a long time ago he probably had
to have meetings with Bob Iger about the
IP because hey you know if they have
access to all these movies Bob iger's
gonna want to know how can they turn
that into money can we make movies with
these characters how's that kind of work
so then Kevin Feige rolls in and gives
him the PowerPoint presentation but
again because of the timeline I think
it's going to be till after Avengers 4
before they actually get any kind of
real clearance to put these characters
in the Marvel movies so until then it
will just be Easter Egg level and
they'll just leave the old start tower
empty because I think before this Fox
deal ever went down they had originally
planned on turning that Avengers tower
into the Oscorp tower and they were
gonna slowly work in some of the bigger
spider-man characters that they didn't
want to start off with like the whole
thing behind the sinister six is that
Green Goblin is still a very big
character but they've done him so many
times in the films that they don't want
to recycle that but he's too big to not
do eventually so I think the idea is
they just slowly worked the idea of
Norman Osborn into the MCU without
actually doing Green Goblin so that you
can just do them down the road if they
renew their sharing arrangement because
right now they only have a deal to use
spider-man through both of these next
Avengers films spider-man homecoming 2
and then that's it then they have to
renew their agreement before they can do
a third spider-man homecoming film or
put them in more Avengers films which
given the Fox deal I think will totally
happen because they want Peter to be in
an Avengers team with x-men characters
eventually that would just be too big to
not do and can you imagine Disney and
Kevin Feige trying to sweeten the deal
for Sony like hey if Yuri sign your
sharing arrangement with us and let us
continue to use the Peter Parker
character we will give you access to the
Deadpool universe
your r-rated spider-verse movies so can
you imagine an eventual Tom Hardy venom
crossover with Deadpool
that would be comedic gold and I know
everybody wants to see some version of
Spidey pool that is totally possible but
the problem is is the Deadpool is such a
hard art character and that's so not
what Tom Hollands Peter Parker is that
it'd be kind of difficult to build up to
that so the workaround to that is that
they just promote each other's movies
and do funny promos without actually
doing a Spidey pool movie because then
you would have to bring the Deadpool
character down to like a pg-13 and I
don't think that people want that but on
the other cosmic side of this the reason
why I included Silver Surfer in that
clip at the beginning is is because he
is the Herald of Galactus in fact during
the infinity war storyline he's the
person that comes to tell dr. strange
that Thanos is coming with the Infinity
Gauntlet so you can see in the infinity
war trailer that they've given that to
the Bruce Banner character because they
had to make that movie a long time
before this Fox deal ever closed so what
they can do is is that by the time this
deal clears and they get to Marvel phase
4 they can introduce the idea of Silver
Surfer in the cosmic movies cross him
over with the guardians of the galaxy
Adam warlock stories that they're
getting ready for in your new cosmic Big
Bad can be the Galactus character a
Marvel version of Galactus no more
crabby looking space anus remember thor
ragnarok the devil's anus one of the
funniest moments in the film moving into
deadpool MCU crossover before this fox
deal was ever announced Josh Brolin was
playing cable but he was also playing
Thanos in The Avengers movies both
Avengers movies he will be back for
Avengers 4 so there were already a lot
of Marvel MCU jokes in the first
Deadpool movie
so naturally we should all expect some
well-timed Cable purple man jokes
because James Gunn and a bunch of other
people behind Marvel have come out since
this Fox deal was announced and said do
not worry Deadpool will still be rated R
Disney's not going to be changing those
movies anytime soon don't worry about it
the easy way to cross him over with the
MCU is to not do a literal crossover is
just to let him make fun of
all the characters the same way he makes
fun of the x-men characters lets us go
talk to the Rufus McAvoy or Stewart
these diamonds so just imagine Deadpool
doing his own thing off by himself in
referencing making fun of things that
happened during the MCU movies so that
way he can still be rated R he can be as
hardcore as ever and you don't wind up
creating any kind of logistical problems
but I don't have to talk too much about
the actual x-men characters the x-men
teams I think what they should probably
do is just recast the characters that
they want to in three or four years like
they have the Dark Phoenix movie coming
up release that who cares how much money
it makes because Disney will be getting
the character shortly if it bombs it
bombs if it does great that's wonderful
but which it probably happen is is when
they get the opportunity just reboot
that franchise and if they want to then
start crossing it over but the big
difference from the Deadpool franchise
is is that the Disney CEO did say that
he was very happy to bring those x-men
characters to the MCU so he was very
clear about continuing to make Deadpool
movies keeping that its own thing that's
not the case for x-men so eventually
there will be x-men characters on screen
with MCU characters but that will
probably be much much further off like
we're talking four or five years at
least because it's gonna take 18 months
minimum for the government to approve
this buyout but let me know in the
comments James Gunn doesn't get the OK
to use a Galactus and Silver Surfer
until after guardians 3 is done which
movie do you want to see them pop up in
first there is a new round of that IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post a Marvel
video or actually it's for Star Wars so
I'll just announce the winner in the
next Star Wars video that I post later
tonight so while you wait for that you
can click here to learn all about Star
Wars Episode nine and you can click here
for all my last Jedi Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]